two years ago Denis Mueller qur'anic set
a new speed record on her bike but it
wasn't on a regular bike or on the track
it was on this and she was pedaling at
nearly the speed that a Boeing 737 hits
during takeoff it's like a Nirvana
that's like I didn't get a feel that
that often and it was so awesome
yulik Heretic was pulled behind a car to
90 miles an hour across Utah's
Bonneville Salt Flats before she
released her tow cord and began pedaling
under her own power in the vehicles
draft and became the first woman to ride
147 miles per hour on a bicycle now she
wants to become the fastest person on a
bike and I am going out to set the
ultimate record and beat 167 miles an
hour
athletes when they talk about being in
the zone it's because the world shuts
off everywhere except for what you're in
the midst of and when I was behind the
vehicle in 2016 the focus that is
necessary it is a life-and-death
situation so there is nothing else going
on that singular focus and the thrill of
extreme speed have drawn a select group
of Daredevils for more than a century
there are not very many people who have
done this record there were no other
women before myself in 2016 that I have
ever attempted this record and there's
about probably close to a dozen men that
have done this since 1899 and in 1899
the first record holder which is the one
that established this was Charles
mile-a-minute Murphy and he did it
behind a train
they put planks down between the tracks
and he went a mile a minute so 60 miles
an hour so he established this record
they did it then in the nineteen 1900s
behind motorcycles and since then it's
been done behind vehicles the vehicle
creates an air pocket that reduces the
normal air resistance on a fast writer
at the back of the air pocket an area of
greater pressure pushes the bike forward
and I'm floating forward and back when
I'm sort of floating back I am pushing
everything I can into those cranks to
where I don't shoot out the back end of
the draft when I hit the back end of the
draft it's like catching that wave sort
of pushes me forward and now
like petaline because I don't want to
slam into the rear of the vehicle
the current record set by Dutch rider
Fred Rumple burg is 167 miles per hour
Mueller qur'anic thinks she can beat it
her bike is getting tuned up and she's
headed back to the salt with the plan to
become the fastest person on two wheels
breaking this record actually will be
huge on multiple levels I mean
personally because it's a goal we set
out but number two is there's a few
records out there where no matter if
you're a female or a male that you can
compete fairly on and this is one of
those records she took me to the track
to show me how she trains by riding to
nearly 40 miles an hour behind an
electric motorcycle naturally I had to
try it myself we hit about 30 and I was
trying to keep tight on his back wheel
because you wind up getting a lot of
free speed if you slip right into his
draft can't imagine doing that you know
five or six times that speed to go that
fast you need a fast car so we went to
the custom auto shop where the drag
racer that she's going to draft behind
is being rebuilt this is my workspace so
you've got that fat metal bumper out on
the front of the bikes covered in green
tape and that'll just come up hit right
up against this let you write it as
close as you want yeah but really a lot
of people they go oh my gosh so you're
hitting something at a hundred and like
fifty or seventy miles an hour and it's
like not really cuz they're I'm going
150 it may be going 150 - it's a 2 mile
an hour really bump so it's a very small
it's a 2 mile per hour tap at 150 miles
an hour ok and she even let me try to
ride the ridiculous bike she'll be using
in her record attempt the single gear
bicycle custom-made and there's no way
to turn that gear because you only have
one gear it's like having a car that's
only has overdrive you're not gonna pull
out of the parking lot and overdrive you
have to get to a speed where that engine
can then crank the gears really pedaling
as hard as I can I don't know if you can
see this my leg is hot I'm putting all
my weight just doesn't work that well
does it there you go one more round on
your own oh he's doing very well
everything about the bike is custom
designed for extreme speed it has double
reduction gearing that makes it nearly
impossible to ride until it's going more
than 50 miles an hour the carbon fiber
frame is extra long and stable and built
around 17-inch motorcycle tires that can
withstand ludicrous speeds on abrasive
salty there's even a specifically made
tow hitch release of course if you're
gonna pedal a triple digit speeds you
don't do it in regular cycling clothes
if God forbid anything where do it
happen and I go down I need to slide it
out and if I'm wearing just Micra that's
not gonna feel very good because it's
salt to talk about salt in the wound
right anyhow so I'm wearing an eight
pound leather Kevlar and neoprene suit
Mueller quranic' has sponsors supporting
her new record attempt here's how it'll
go down I start from 0 miles per hour
attached and tethered to the vehicle I
have to be towed up to a speed at which
my legs can turn that gear over and so I
release right around the mild a mile and
a quarter mark at about 90 miles an hour
and I stay in the draft if all goes
according to plan
Mueller qur'anic will set a new record
riding faster than 167 miles per hour I
want to do at least 170 miles an hour of
course the closer we get and the more
everybody has their input they're like
you can do 195 I think you can do 200
it's like okay let's at least get to the
170 that will be happy with that
[Music]